Cheltenham is just around the corner but
forget the Gold Cup this is the gold pop
same sort of thing but the noble steeds
replaced by docile canine this is sponge
dog square Bank not well fancied by the
book is due to those less than
aerodynamically whoa easy boy
he's full of beans in it for my lightly
pull a pedigree chomp now this is well
odds revenge to that wrinkle facial
experience and sculpted physique she's a
decent punch a very lean we are here
song chops to pay his poochie's home
planet long body low center of gravity
Jim Jam the notorious p ug here cool
calm collected totally in the zone
today's full race cars and wonderful
funds in there so much concentration so
much at stake so much for my career
prospects and the serious sports
broadcast with there are three companies
witnessing on the back strict no no wait
really Charlotte going on here all right
now back oppa I think I got paws like
traction engine slow-mo replay will give
us a better insight into life and pu g
seems to really calm in the build-up but
now that's looking like total
complacently for him
look at those leaks from the rest of the
field taking on that fencing doggy style
well as revenge very nearly Cesar dreams
of gold pop victory shatter to that flip
having the first bank with what a
recovery but it's all about that battle
for second so close full to finish
needed LL Cool J takes it on the bridle
and what some out be Yugi feels for
confirmation of the results there allows
revenge takes the gold pop while LL Cool
J narrowly been poochy gold granite into
second place or top reassembled and the
trophy brow winner is happy
lick lick away lick like you've never
lived before bad either
you